an emotional week of testimony ended
with the prosecution moving to a new
stage of their case in the derrick
shovin murder trial
investigators took the stand friday next
week we expect them to introduce
experts who are likely to say chauvin's
knee to the neck
is what caused george floyd's death
cbs's jamie yukis takes us
inside the case the most
senior officer in the minneapolis police
department took the stand friday
lieutenant richard zimmerman was called
to investigate what happened the day
george floyd died and told the jury
derrick chauvin
violated police policy if your knee is
on a person's neck
that can kill him this marked the end of
a trying week in the courtroom
my instincts were telling me that
something's wrong 911 dispatcher jenna
scurry testified that she called the
police
on the police after seeing what was
happening on a surveillance camera
then mixed martial artist donald
williams testified about watching floyd
die
and calling 9-1-1 and why did you do
that
because i believe i witnessed a murder
check his fault bro the defense focused
on williams behaviors toward the
officers that day
after you called him a bum 13 times you
called him a phone
that's what you heard the prosecution's
next witness
darnella frazier shot this now infamous
cell phone video
it wasn't right he was he was suffering
he was in pain
she was among four witnesses whose faces
were not shown
on camera because they were minors at
the time
it's been nice i stayed up
apologizing in
and apologizing
to george floyd for not doing more new
body camera video revealed for the first
time
chauvin's reaction control this guy
because he's a sizable guy
looks like he's coming on something the
prosecution also showed never before
seen video
of floyd inside cup foods employee
christopher martin briefly spoke
with floyd it would appear that he was
high martin says floyd used what
appeared to be a counterfeit 20 dollar
bill
leading to another worker calling the
police what was going through your mind
during that time period disbelief thank
god
why guilt if i would have just
not taken the bill this could have been
avoided the prosecution played dramatic
video of the ambulance team's arrival
you can see paramedic seth bravender
make a hand gesture at chauvin to move
as his partner derek smith checked
floyd's pulse
what did his condition appear to be to
you overall
in late terms i thought he was dead
floyd's girlfriend
courtney ross also testified about how
they both struggled with
opioid addiction it's a classic story of
how many people get addicted to opioids
we both
suffered from chronic pain when you
weren't
using you know prescription opioids
uh you know where did you get them
off the street on the black market
and you knew that he was doing that as
well
yes ross testified that floyd had bought
drugs from maurice hall the person
sitting in the passenger seat of floyd's
suv
on the day of the police encounter he's
refused to testify
citing his fifth amendment right next
week we're expected to hear from the
minneapolis police chief
people will be watching closely to see
how he answers
whether or not one of his former
officers used excessive force on george
floyd
for cbs this morning saturday jamie
yukas minneapolis